South African Police have forcibly
evicted scores of migrants who had been
camping out for weeks in Cape Town
around 100 people were arrested after
violent clashes in front of a United
Nations building now the migrants are
not demanding to stay in fact they want
to leave they say recent wave of
xenophobic violence directed at African
migrants shows South Africa is no longer
safe they came to South Africa to seek
refuge or simply a better future now all
they want is to get out for weeks
hundreds of migrants have been camping
here outside the UN's refugee agency in
Cape Town demanding to be relocated to
other countries but on Wednesday after
an eviction order the police moved in
[Music]
they fired water cannons and stun
grenades
[Applause]
police say they arrested some 100
foreign nationals who refused to
disperse for the protesters the use of
force by the police is fueling anger
over what they call a xenophobic
atmosphere in South Africa many migrants
from other African countries go to South
Africa seeking better job prospects but
after a spate of deadly riots and
attacks in September many say they no
longer feel safe here that's why these
protesters in Cape Town have been
calling on the UN to move them to
another country last week the UN refugee
agency issued a statement saying false
messages were being circulated about
resettlement and that only a very small
number of refugees and asylum seekers
met the criteria but that didn't stop
the protests here
[Music]
after Wednesday's police operation
remaining demonstrators headed on for
now their new home is a local church
where they've been given temporary
shelter off more on this now I'm joined
by a correspondent in at Cape Town
Attica at least good to see you at lien
what is going to happen to these people
now well 100 of them were actually
temporarily arrested yesterday they are
released in the meantime and it is
likely that they will keep on protesting
but it is very unlikely that their
demands will be met we've heard it they
do not want to stay here because I don't
feel safe here they don't want to go
back to their countries of origin they
want to go to other countries some
protesters yesterday suggested Dubai
Europe the USA Canada and this is just
simply not going to happen South Africa
has about 270,000 refugees and asylum
seekers imagine what kind of message
that would send if some of them now are
allowed to go and remember also that not
all of them are really refugees were
running away from violence in their
countries we've seen protesters from
Kenya for example and they are running
away because of economic situations and
at the moment the economic situation in
South Africa is not much better than in
their countries of origin this is why
many of them are frustrated and this is
why they want to go the catalan in that
report we saw a tough response from
police why did the Cape Town police
crack down so hard on this protest
so the protesters have been gathering in
front of the UNHCR office for weeks and
it is in a building where there's also
other offices so some people took them
to court asked the police to remove them
and this is what happened yesterday it
is of course very questionable the force
that was used to disperse the crowds
yesterday you've seen it water cannons
tear gas there were women injured
children had to see how their own
parents got beaten after this is very
questionable and this should be
investigated and I suppose the broader
question of course why has xenophobia
become such a big problem in South
Africa you see ever since the end of
apartheid 25 years ago the hopes of the
people were really well destroyed I have
to say because there were so many hope
see that the country would improve for
the poor my majority of the country and
nothing much really happened and this is
why a lot of frustration came up if we
look at the current situation here about
60% of the youth is unemployed this year
alone another half a million people out
of work this is a massive problem and
this is what of course also caused this
xenophobic attacks that we have seen in
September people fighting for the little
that is available I don't want to
justify that of course it's terrible
what we've seen here but what we also
have to say to clarify this there's an
ax for big attacks that happened in
September did not happen in Cape Town
they happened in other cities like in
Johannesburg going t SH in Cape Town
putting it into perspective for us thank
you very much